we have a voicemail number that number
remains 219 to David P we've been
talking on the world famous bonus show
lately about what's going on with
Netflix accounts oh the bonus show where
you want to make money but everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
as bad we make a little bit of money on
the bonus show sure uh the big thing
that's happening with Netflix accounts
is a Crackdown no more sharing accounts
between people who don't live together
and I I admitted I'm still on my mommy's
account that's absolutely true it has
all my preferences and my likes and
dislikes and I've been on that account
for I don't know 20 years and I'm gonna
stay on it until they take it away from
me and the Eggman called in to weigh in
on this
hey Dave my daughter turned 21 years old
today happy birthday to her birthday
present for her I told her she can
remain on our Netflix accounts for 30
more years
just like you and your family Shalom
brother yep that's absolutely right I've
got my account on my mom's account my
profile uh my little brother has one as
well
and uh I'm sticking with it until
Netflix takes it away and uh we will see
how long that is we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today
Ultra processed foods what is that
what's the difference between processed
and Ultra processed well we will talk
about it Ultra processed foods may lead
to cognitive decline says a new study is
the study trustworthy we will discuss we
have really good news about Salman
Rushdie
he is back to a certain degree
um we're going to talk about it some
some amazing pictures of Salman Rushdie
published in the New Yorker and we're
going to talk about the aftermath of
that horrible horrible attack that he
was the victim of and lastly the virus
threat is easing from covid but U.S
hospitals are as full as they have ever
been why what is the reason well we're
going to talk about it it's not from
respiratory disease it's from other
things all of those stories and more are
on two days bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com you will get instant
access to the show it's really cheap to
sign up
but I understand that many folks would
like a discount and I'm glad to offer
one you can use the coupon code
please no more Trump that's all one word
no spaces please no more Trump you can
use that coupon code to get a discount
off of the cost of a membership and I
want you to remember that we continue
the fight for 2 million YouTube
subscribers you can help us for free by
signing up at youtube.com the
davidpackman show and by the way voting
you can only do once if you have
multiple Google accounts you can
subscribe to the YouTube channel
multiple times perfectly legal Carrie
Lakes not coming after you for it
pillows not coming after you for
nobody's coming after you for it so just
just mentioning it just mentioning it we
will see you on the bonus show or
otherwise back tomorrow on the Friday
show